- [Narrator] In the center
of Seoul, South Korea,
there's a neighborhood known as Yongsan.
Most people had no reason to come here.
It was a little rough around the edges.
(speaking foreign language)
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This is Kim Yun-kyu,
he's the main guy leading
the charge to convince young people
and small businesses to open shop.
(all laughing)
To be part of Passion Island,
you have to live locally
and stay true to the
spirit of the neighborhood.
- [Narrator] This
ongoing change has turned
the neighborhood from one of the scariest,
to one of the coolest places in town.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] This is a
pretty radical business plan
in South Korea, but
these ideas are working.
Passion Island is now the hip place to be.
(shouting in foreign language)